o pessoal bem 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma arma que eu não sei como se
chama hora uma vez que ela te para
vários tipos de município em ti é a
primeira que eu gosto mais de ver o
lance de dados que pode ser associado
uma harmonia que é hoje maior custas e
estar me param quando vocês puxa o dedo
pra frente o tamanho de parar bolinhas
da uft em uma versão assim shopping uma
vez que mandar bom instrutor lado o
então a versão spider man las até isso
então vamos lá primeiro tem que rolar
uma folha consultou a fifa é que ela das
feiras
caso você não consiga fazer isso direito
e vou deixar um link de inscrição ensina
a fazer isso mais lugar próximo passo
após fazer falta em que o flamengo foi a
volta de modo a fazer um twin quando
estiver tudo de lado e vejo estado pleno
confira
para finalizar tudo time pudesse grande
e prendeu o outro lado a outro precisa
fazer mais um guia de tubo
então é só colar mais uma folha volta
para usar estavam precisarão ter dois
tipos de tubo e derivados
[Música]
permite usar aqui uma caixa de um jogo
toda a gente em jogos em casa então aí
command universal depois corta
vamos lá ficar com dida maior respaldo
em uma rifa
ele é parte mais frágil dos lados e
meçam para ficar do tamanho da partida
vocês cortaram anteriormente ou seja tem
cortaram foi do tamanho de uma caixa de
jogo vou usar em que cola rápida
vocês podem usar outras coisas quaisquer
cair neste projeto não vai fazer muita
diferença
pega em dois clubes grandes e corp em 5
docinho da ponta mais ou menos 34
centímetros corta os dois tubos e aéreos
agora tem por cola nenhum dos lados da
parte branca foi um tubinho grande e
todo lado tem a mesma coisa
ensinar de uma das partes que sobrou do
grande corta aquela inclinação tem a
parte mais frágil de uma dois livros e
quarto tempo também de uma caixa de jogo
muita atenção nesta para tem força um
crime de cola
num dos lados da rifa e introduzir desta
maneira que o tubo verde
aí tem que produzir de modo que o quarto
corte fica virada para cima vejo que é
melhor perder ficar com estas peças vão
querer um lado temos um branco e outro
temos neve foi branca
então lá deve ficar branca vocês têm que
fazer um corte que eu estou assim lag
tem que ser mesmo lado rival cair foi o
outro pode não funcionar estar muito
papel papel normal a gente vocês
perguntei então para ficar mais forte um
cenário de uma super cola e por nos
lugares onde estou por isso vai aumentar
pois tenta assistencialistas
se vocês forem crianças peçam ajuda o
outro a cair para fazer o gatilho
assim a parte mais frágil uma rifa e a
massa em um pouco conta deste modo a
fazer mais com o triângulo mineiro
voltar à ponta disse para ficar mais
resistente que vocês vão ver o incêndio
instalado eu vou fazer assim may que uma
dobra com a deixar lhe um pequeno
orifício para depois encaixar o fio que
depois vou prender esse fio ao dedo para
disparar
inicialmente eu aprendi com cola e para
ficar mais forte ainda procura um pedaço
de fita
o zac efron do fio passar pelo orifício
na alguns nós
eu vou deixar ele mais ou menos uns 15
centímetros
depois de estar ao meu dele vejam que é
o tempo aponta desta quarta o gatilho e
senta ali um pedacinho do pãozinho
churrasco com cola
vocês podem usar do primeiro jeito como
os três se você usar um pontinho vai
ficar mais resistentes para impulsionar
as balas num cenário de elásticos
podemos eu acho que se vocês acharem
criar uma vai aguentar e não abusa
pronto e nesta partida não tenha parte
do pão e vinho como eu fiz lá eu fiz só
depois daquela tutorial é mais um sinal
dos 27 choque toque com o coletivo
funciona melhor para fixar a arma voz do
braço avançado um retângulo do plano
eu usei um pedaço de uma caixa de
cerveja
como podem ver bastante simples desde
está de cortar um docinho de uma rifa de
largura deste rectângulo depois corta em
mais um desenho igual vincular os tipos
dos índios na arma é mais cuidado quando
vocês forem acumulará tem que ter em
atenção para que a cola não contacto com
os elásticos contactar pronto os latics
vamos treinar
vocês podem fazer literário oscilação e
popular
quando tiver a cola já seca podem votar
o povo
vejam que estou por cola novamente
nessas partes brancas
agora claro que não suporta
e agora mostrar como fazer a versão
homem aranha
o jogo aqui um tubinho produzir uma rifa
prender o filme deste modo a encaixar lá
dentro e é preciso agora marcar o fio
eu marquei um fio para criar depois
quando foram caminhar é mais fácil vocês
dobrarem desde já tentou juntar as
partes pintadas e vou ficar lá em
posição para largar
vejam que é bastante fácil de carregar é
só introduzir o tubo que não tem nada lá
dentro
[Música]
agora vocês encaixando nosso braço o
rosto dele
então vocês podem prender uma argola de
bairro ou até mais fácil depois de
disparar
e agora pra prender vocês podem usar
fita maggi eo também depois usando uma
mola na roupa para aprender as duas
partes querem uma mola você expõe alien
segura bem e já está
quanta gente parar só puxar o livro dele
e só chegamos ao fim e espero que tenham
gostado se vocês quiserem dar o canal se
deixar um leque se inscreveu caso não
seja o script é isso ela tinha um pitboy
amanhã